hi Matt I'm transgender I'm born and
raised here in New Mexico I have a
graduate degree in information
technology marketing business and
finance I own my own home I pay taxes I
have a six-figure job I'm a respected
professional in Albuquerque I'm a mother
uh
my life experience is that I'm an
awesome person I am well liked I'm
responsible and
I think I'm pretty cool
uh you touched on something you said
something earlier that for you and
somebody calls you a man it doesn't
phase you because like you just know
that you're a man uh
that was interesting to me because I
feel the same way about my identity as a
woman
my question leading up to this
you've asserted that no one would ever
see me as a woman
that
nobody would ever see or could see a
transgender person as a woman and yet
I have
dozens of friends from diverse
backgrounds women from the reservation a
woman from Japan uh several immigrant
women I have my co-workers I have my
boss my VP my CEO all respecting me as a
woman uh my family my long-term friends
who are actually here with me
I all of these people assure me
like
I'm a woman they'll tell me girl like
there is no way you're a man they see me
as a woman so the question okay how can
you assert
that nobody would ever see me as a woman
when my material experience tells me
you're wrong okay it's interesting that
that's the part of my talk you chose to
ask a question about because that's not
in my talk at all
um I don't believe I said that no one
would ever see you as a woman I mean
it's possible I suppose that you could
fool someone now you brought this up so
I have to tell you that uh you brought
this up you've put your identity on the
table for conversation and so I'm going
to say you you wouldn't fool me at all I
mean I see a man 100 and I think that
most people would now the the fact the
fact that you have people in your life
who are saying to you oh you're totally
a woman it's exactly what I'm talking
about no one in my life has ever once
said to me
you're totally a man Matt you know if my
if if if if a friend of mine called me
on the phone and said listen Matt I want
you to know
you're really a man
I would think that there was something
wrong with him I would say why are you
saying that at all doesn't make any
sense so the fact this is a conversation
to begin with tells me it only it only
proves the point that I'm trying to make
that that your identity even in your own
mind is up for is something that you
need to be assured of now what I what I
would like to ask you again because
you're standing here and and so
uh you've brought your identity and on
the table for discussion so uh how did
you how do you know that you're a woman
uh it was first when I heard transgender
persons describe their experience in
their own words and this was only about
two years ago uh hearing somebody
describe things it was a woman from like
England describing her experience her
childhood uh her teenage years
and it blew my mind to be listening to
her because it was just some podcast
that I was listening to while I was like
doing laundry
but it blew my mind to hear somebody so
eloquently and precisely describe things
that I had experiences
what did they say
um Okay so
I am honestly hesitant I know that you
touched earlier about the difficulty
that transgender women might have in
describing their identity but I want to
state
I honestly don't feel that you would
engage in this conversation in good
faith
so why are you here why did you stand up
to talk to me if you don't want to have
a conversation
you're saying that you discover that
you're a woman I'm asking you how you
did that's a very fair question okay how
do you know that you're a woman that's
fine
all right so first of all listening to
transgender people and it was like okay
this is a one-off you know one person
describing these things
um things like looking at yourself in
the mirror and not recognizing yourself
uh hearing compliments like you are such
an example like a positive masculine
role model and just hearing that and
being like you know it feels like
they're talking about somebody else
um it means feeling alone even when
you're surrounded by guys even when you
have a lot of friends and I was active
in like Boy Scouts I'm an eagle scout I
had great masculine Role Models my whole
life and yet I never felt
like I belonged I felt welcome and why
does that make you a woman
as opposed to just a man who doesn't get
along with some other men or a man who's
who's depressed or a man who doesn't
feel at home totally in his body which
by the way is a is a pretty Universal
Human Experience everybody goes through
it one time and another so so in what
way does that make you a woman though
it's interesting you're telling me that
you listen to the experience of other
transgender people well yeah but what
about women
so you're because you are trans women
are women you would say right I would
say that yeah exactly the same yes okay
well then why do you need to hear the
testimony of trans quote unquote trans
women like how how you pick any actual
woman in this room
in what way do you know that you belong
in the same category as them
uh I know because they tell me so here
was the you need them to tell you what
you are women
yes I trust the opinions of the women
around and it's mostly it's incredible
you might try it if most women voted and
said they don't see you as a woman would
you say I'm not a woman anymore
if who if most women voted and said they
don't see you as a woman anymore would
you then relent and say I'm not a woman
I would say most people on the planet
have no idea who I am I'm gonna trust
the opinions of the people who've spent
their lives with me
so you but you are relying on other
people to tell you who you are is what
we're establishing
for context I know you would like to
think I know you like to say
um
I know you like to say uh everybody's
raw rawing and supporting transgender
people and yet they're still killing
themselves Etc
um but I'm standing here in a room full
of people applauding you and asking
questions like how can I like put out
legislation here in New Mexico you know
my home state I grew up in to try to
reverse transgenderism like
I'm not safe
and it's not safe you just said you're
standing in a room people disagree with
you and you're perfectly fine so how are
you not safe
like okay look we're going round around
you you don't want to answer any of the
questions maybe we'll just we'll end
with this because we're talking about
Womanhood
so people could probably shout out the
question I'm going to ask you right now
okay but uh you know that you're a woman
yes
what is that
I
so gender is a social thing it only
makes sense what is a woman what is a
woman what is a woman word woman defined
in the dictionary go
a woman is somebody who is included and
respected and seen and participates in
society recognized by other women if you
speak with women
circular definition that's mine whatever
okay all right okay
[Music]
[Applause]